the tears of a couple who starved and
locked up 12 of their children David and
Louise Turpin were jailed for life after
pleading guilty to years of torture and
abuse in an emotional hearing some of
their children spoke publicly about it
for the first time my parents took my
whole life for me but now I'm taking my
life back I'm in college now and living
independently I love hanging out with my
friends and life is great I believe
everything happens for a reason
life may have been bad but it made me
strong I fought to become the person I
am sometimes I still have nightmares of
things that had happened such as my
siblings being chained up or getting
beaten but that is the past and this is
now
I love both of my parents so much
although it may not have been the best
way of raising us I'm glad that they did
because it made me the person I am today
the horror in the house southeast of Los
Angeles was concealed by a veneer of
normality but inside the children who
ranged in age from 2 to 29 years old
lived in squalor beaten caged and
shackled they were saved by the couple's
17 year old daughter who jumped out of a
window to tell police that some of her
siblings were chained to their beds with
his rings remarry two adults who were
meant to love and protect instead chose
to isolate and neglect
now they insist they're sorry Cordelia
Lynch Sky News Washington